vous êtes en direct sur brut en
exclusivité donc ici sur la place
clemenceau tout d'abord cette première
question on a pu voir hier des documents
de la préfecture de police a fuité sur
les réseaux sociaux
est ce que vous en confirmer
l'authenticité si oui quelle est votre
réaction
alors son développement administratif
avait envoyé à plus de 2000 personnes et
donc ce n'est pas un secret d'état
c'est un des ventes d'actions qui a
diffusé très largement sur l'ensemble
des policiers parisiens
ça n'est pas une fuite ce n'est pas une
fuite donc non mais par contre j'ai pas
normal qu'ils se retrouvent là et donc
j'ai demandé au préfet de police et une
enquête administrative pour voir dans
quelle mesure certains membres
destinataires des soins très grand
nombre de ces documents trouve normal de
les diffuser à l'extérieur donc je sais
c'est à minima une anomalie
on est donc à l'aube d'une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui
c'est un dispositif impressionnant
certains disent qu'on n'a jamais vu ça
depuis mai 68 c'est ça qu'est ce que
t'as prescience la violence dont paris
la province de nombreuses préfectures
ont fait l'objet la semaine dernière et
donc
nous avons voulu apporter une réponse
forte et d'abord la première c'est celle
de la prudence c'est celle la prévenance
moi j'appelle vraiment celles et ceux j
les jeunes qui veulent porter un message
militants à ne pas se mêler aux casseurs
on sait que les casseurs ne sont fort
que parce que il se déguise en gilet
jaune et qu' ils s'immiscent il se met
au milieu des jupes des jeunes
il gêne du coup les interventions de nos
forces de sécurité et puis il ya aussi
des jeunes qui se sont radicalisés la
violence n'est jamais une façon de
manifester de revendiquer le
gouvernement a tendu la main a fait de
nombreuses propositions a fait des
efforts il y avait un sujet emblématique
était la cause de la mobilisation au
début c'était la taxe sur les produits
pétroliers a été supprimé et donc elle
ne s'appliquera pas maintenant il faut
se mettre autour de la table et discuter
certains ajustements dans les
commentaires parce qu'on est en direct
sur facebook ils disent que le
gouvernement a joué la stratégie du
pourrissement n'a pas pris au sérieux au
début de mouvement d gilet jaune a pris
beaucoup de temps répond que c'est une
situation évitables qu'est-ce que vous
ne répondez tête dès le premier jour
j'ai mobilisé cinquante cinq mille
policiers et gendarmes tant qu'amateur
ne pas prendre au sérieux je connais
mieux gdm mobilisez vous savez pas pour
les protéger les manifestants et qui
soit 620 ici un lieu au niveau des
revendications
et si côté ans les a entendus on leur a
tendu la main très tôt dans la
discussion mais on n'a pas
d'interlocuteur c'est toute la
difficulté que nous avons
moi je pense que ce mouvement a fait
naître un monstre qui est né de colère
de colère ancien qui est en ce pays et
que personne aujourd'hui ne peut le
tenir donc il faut il faut le ramener
dans la table de discussion il faut le
ramener dans le débat il faut le ramener
dans la discussion parlementaire qui a
aussi sa place pour remettre l'église au
milieu du village vous savez moi je fais
confiance aux 36 m me le maire de france
qu'ils connaissent leur territoire et
auraient été élus qui peuvent parler au
nom du territoire je fais confiance aux
parlementaires de l'opposition de la
majorité parce que ils ont cette
légitimité là parlons ensemble c'est ce
qu'on propose dans les jours qui
viennent
partout en france on pourra discuter par
les avancées prévues le champ north
qu'elles étaient ouverts manifestants le
24 novembre le 1er décembre c'était un
périmètre sur les champs elysées est ce
qu'aujourd'hui un périmètre qui est
ouvert aux manifestants qui
souhaiteraient manifester de façon
pacifique à paris et quelques
déclarations qui ont été faites la
difficulté c'est qu'aucune ne semble
suffisamment sérieuse mais relayé donc
c'est toute la difficulté vous savez
quand on a proposé les champs elysées la
semaine dernière de tout temps les mises
l'intérieur ont refusé moi j'ai voulu
que ce soit une main tendue justement au
gie des jeunes pour faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent manifester là où ils
voulaient manifester dans des conditions
de sécurité
résultat au fond il n'y a eu que sept
cent cinquante manifestants les autres
sont restés avec les classeurs et
beaucoup ont cassé il a aujourd'hui un
périmètre qui ouvert en particulier
c'est vraiment notre addiction
manifester générale pour les régions
aujourd'hui son pari prophète nous
n'avons interdit aucune rue tout
simplement une manifestation en france à
se déclarer
ça ne s'autorise pas ça se déclare et
quand elle est déclarée que se
déroulaient correctement
elle permet de discuter avec des forces
de sécurité pour protéger les
manifestants pour protéger les commerces
la celle et ceux qui appellent à venir
ici à paris et partout au poste n'ont
rien déclarer pour eux manifestement le
droit se limite à leurs propres
revendications et à leurs seules
revendications et vous avez quelques
chants très nombreux c'est très diverses
que répondez vous à ceux qui vous disent
que c'est la stratégie de la peur
d'avoir voilà on sait que l'elysée par
exemple c'est dans les jours à venir on
redoute qui les casseurs à qui n'aime
pas les gens qui viennent pour tuer
c'est des mots extrêmement forts
qu'est ce qui vous fait redouter que le
niveau de violence soient plus élevés
aujourd'hui que les journées précédentes
mais déjà la peur elle était dans les
yeux de celles et ceux que j'ai vu à
quelques mètres et 10 c au commissariat
du viiième et qui m'ont raconté ce
qu'ils ont vécu
quand ils ont été attaqués quand on a
voulu jeter des corps quand on a jeté
des cocktails molotov et des gaz lacrymo
dans leur véhicule quand on avenue
les tuer et ce sont leurs bon look cette
peur elle était là la semaine dernière
alors on aurait pu la cacher mais je
pense que vous journalistes vous nous
aurez rocheuses de la cacher moi je joue
franc jeu depuis le début je donne le
nombre de manifestants le nombre de
forces mobilisées
je donne les moyens de manifester dans
de bonnes conditions
et quand ce que vous avez en face sont à
la fois désorganisé et c'est la version
soft mais aussi sont des casseurs qui
viennent pour casser c'est ça la réalité
je préfère alerter les gens est ce
qu'aujourd'hui une stratégie plus
offensive de la part de la police il a
beaucoup de dispositifs statique on sait
que dans le maintien de l'ordre et une
idée de ne pas forcément les au contact
des manifestants utilisent notamment des
gaz lacrymogènes est ce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya cette idée d'être plus offensif
vis-à-vis des des manifestants des zones
de tension actes et bon on avait une
doctrine d'emploi comme on dit qui fait
que pour éviter des blessés c'est un
objectif permanent il y a eu quelques
blessés mais assez peu vu la violence de
la situation d'une plus de blessés
d'ailleurs dans les forces de l'ordre
depuis le début des manifestations que
du côté des manifestants
parce que justement on est dans cette
idée du cantonnement
on a vu quand même les limites surtout
cela ça des gens qui veulent commettre
des actes guerrier et donc le mode
d'intervention a changé
il y aura plus de contrôle plus
d'interventions directes est-ce que le
gouvernement va encore faire des gestes
dans les prochains jours on parle par
exemple d'une prime qui pourrait donner
aux salariés à plusieurs pistes
actuellement en cours est ce qu'il ya
des choses qui pourraient évoluer donc
dans les prochaines heures dans les
prochains jours c'est ce que beaucoup
attendent aujourd'hui parce que vous
autorisez vous savez moi je suis là car
je pense qu'elle va sécréter me dites
pas c'est ce que font toujours attendre
si on devait faire la liste de toutes
les revendications des jets des jeunes
ont commencé par supprimer brut ont
commencé par interdire les médias parce
que j'ai entendu ça certains veulent un
militaire à la tête du gouvernement
ça fait partie des revendications
d'autres veulent supprimer le sénat doit
laufon supprimer la démocratie je sais
pas si certaines roues parler son
candidat supprimer la démocratie moi je
suis attaché non de la république a été
élu il y a dix huit mois par le peuple
français
ils la légitimité peut-être un peu plus
forte que celle des dix mille personnes
qui depuis trois semaines manifestent
dans les rues
moi je crois que respecter la démocratie
respecter les médias à respecter nos
forces de sécurité c'est peut-être le
premier combat non violent
nous devons mener est l'une des
revendications des manifestants lors ya
eu cet axe qui ont été supprimés mais ce
pouvoir d'achat immédiat si les
manifestants qui vous disent voilà moi
dès le 10 et le 15 du mois je n'arrive
plus à boucler la fin de mois comment
faire pour améliorer les choses
aujourd'hui c'est des taxes qui permet
de ne pas détériorer la situation est
pour eux les comment faire pour
améliorer leur pouvoir d'achat
immédiatement c'est ça aujourd'hui la
réponse que certains sans attendre sur
le terrain qu'est ce que vous l'aurez
tombé assez lent pas toujours faire
comme mon affaire avant de tribus
l'argent des autres 2000 milliards
d'euros de dette il ya une mesure simple
apprendre qu'on décide d'augmenter
toutes les fonctions de france c'est qui
paye les pensions en france ce sont soit
arrière
soit nos petits-enfants avec la bête
c'est pas l'état et pourtant des
manifestants disent il faut augmenter
les retraites
et c'est vrai que les petites retraites
et c'est vrai que c'est la galère quand
j'étais maire pendant 16 ans dans une
petite commune au général je rencontre
tous temps pas dans mes fonctions
actuelles des gens qui connaissent des
difficultés mais je rencontre aussi des
parents qui amènent leurs enfants à
l'école rencontre des parents qui ont un
aîné qui est à l'ehpad de forcalquier je
rencontre les parents qui savent que
leurs enfants pour à l'université
presque gratuitement
c'est ça aussi le service public de la
france est aussi ça c'est l'invité donc
un moment donné il faut séduire
on peut dépenser l'argent qu'on n'a pas
ou alors on fait l'inversé on se dit
qu'on va faire en sorte qu'on puisse
produire de l'argent alors je sais que
c'est inaudible
mais depuis 10 ans n'a pas créé un
emploi industriel dans ce pays et cette
année pour la première fois on en a créé
c'est aussi ça la réalité dont on doit
parler et dont je pense vous devez
parler c'est l'intérêt de ce direct
merci beaucoup merci à vous monsieur
ministre
[Musique]